[Musica]
Avete presente quei periodi della vita
in cui ci si sente disorientati in cui
non si sa che strada prendere come
quando finisci l'università e non sai da
che parte andare nel mondo del lavoro
oppure quando finisce una storia d'amore
veramente importante e vedi il futuro
che avevi immaginato crollare davanti a
te oppure molto più semplicemente quando
ti svegli una mattina e ti rendi conto
che la vita che hai non ti piace però
non sai come cambiarla perché non senti
una voce interiore che ti parla che ti
dice quella è la strada giusta No è
proprio il perché non c'è la strada
giusta per te a un certo punto tutte le
strade cominciano a sembrarti uguali per
proprio perché nessuno resta quella
giusta no E qui in un certo punto
scivoli nell'indifferenza scivoli
nell'apatia Ecco conosco una persona che
ha appena uscita da un periodo come
questo e si chiama Claudio Claudio
ragazzo molto dolce e molto timido però
così timido che una sera eravamo in
discoteca e Eravamo lì a ballare a
sorseggiare metto il link e a un certo
punto si è avvicinata una ragazza si è
avvicinata a Claudio Insomma lei ballava
cercavo un po' di sedurlo no e Claudio
era lì che fissava un punto nel vuoto
col drink in mano e lei a un certo punto
ha detto vabbè ok ho capito non ci sono
speranze se n'è andata no E noi siamo
voltati verso Claudio abbiamo detto ma
scusa Claudio ma quella ragazza non ti
piaceva per niente Non è che tutta la
debba sposare però sai magari farci un
ballo e lui No no ma la ragazza era
bellissima È solo che io non sapevo cosa
dire Non sapevo cosa fare e allora sono
rimasto lì col bicchiere in mano Ecco
questo è Claudio che è un ragazzo un po'
sì un po' timido e neanche un genio un
genio non nel senso che era il primo
della scuola Anzi era proprio il primo
della provincia Claudio ha vinto un
sacco di concorso addirittura regionali
avevo un sacco di potenziale e gli
adulti glielo facevano notare gli
dicevano ascolta me
Guarda che tu diventerai qualcuno
e Claudio però questa cosa la sentiva
come un peso nessuno gli diceva chi
sarebbe diventato diventerai qualcuno
Ok io Questo grande potenziale un
quoziente intellettivo sopra la media o
una grande memoria va bene Quindi se
divento qualcuno è fortuna non è merito
mio E se invece non divento nessuno sarà
colpa mia perché ho sprecato il mio
potenziale e con questo peso Claudio ha
vissuto tutta la sua adolescenza poi è
arrivata all'università e ha scelto
medicina e tutti Ho cominciato a dirgli
che sarebbe diventato primario fino al
giorno della sua laurea dove i suoi
parenti hanno iniziato a fare simpatici
e a dirgli Eh sì tu diventerai primario
però se vuoi fare i soldi eh tutti lo
sanno se volevi fare i soldi dovevi fare
l'avvocato ma che è avvocato devi fare
l'ingegnere informatico Ma va dovevi
fare il manager e loro si sentivano un
po' simpatici ma poi cercavano di fare
quello che aveva un fatto per tutta la
vita far capire a Claudio che poteva
fare qualsiasi cosa Il punto però è che
quel pranzo si è trasformato in un
incubo per Claudio Perché vedeva tutte
le persone che sarebbe potuto diventare
e che non sarebbe diventato
si vedeva che stava male allora ho messo
ravvicinate gli ho detto Senti ma ti va
una tisana ci prendiamo una tisana Una
di queste sere e abbiamo un po' parlato
e Claudio mi ha confidato che ha paura
della vita ma non ha paura della vita in
generale così ha paura di un aspetto
specifico di rimanere incastrato in una
vita che non vuole che non lo rispecchia
lui mi ha detto io ho sempre fatto
quello che mi dicevano gli altri perché
mi sembrava che gli altri fossero più
esperti di me sembrava che tutti
avessero una direzione Eh sì tranne me e
adesso è inutile dirmi Ah no ma tu non
devi fare quello che ti dicono gli altri
Tu devi fare quello che vuoi tu sì però
quello che voglio io non lo so
Ecco siccome Claudio è un grande esperto
d'arte Tra le altre cose ho pensato di
paragonare la sua vita ad un quadro The
battle of hurray Ecco questo quadro ci
sono un sacco di persone non un sacco di
persone che si accapigliano che si fanno
guerra fra loro per dire a Claudio Cosa
deve fare come deve farlo e quando deve
farlo e Claudia è lì sotto in fondo
steso così ecco questo In questo quadro
ci sono tantissime cose tantissime
persone però non si capisce bene dove
guardare no non si capisce subito quale
sia la scena principale perché come in
tutti i quadri medievali manca la
prospettiva e la prospettiva quella cosa
che ci fa capire dove guardare così a
Colpo d'occhio
in arte la prospettiva è la percezione
di profondità e a me piace pensare che
come in arte anche nella vita
prospettiva e profondità siano legati
perché se noi scendiamo nel profondo
dentro noi stessi la nostra vita non
avrà prospettiva sarà piatta e noi non
capiremo che cosa davvero importante
Ecco c'è un poema epico Greco che ha una
prospettiva molto chiara Perché la cosa
importante è soltanto una tornare a casa
si tratta dell'Odissea il poema del
ritorno a casa di Ulisse Ecco
nell'odissea c'è una scena specifica la
scena in cui Ulisse incontra le sirene
una piccola nota le sirene nella
mitologia greca non sono delle
bellissime donne con delle code sinuose
ma sono dei brutti pennuti Ecco questo è
un dipinto È dipinto su un vaso
conservato nel British Museum e risale
al quinto secolo avanti Cristo Ecco in
sintesi per i greci le sirene sono
quegli Uccellacci molto aggressivi che
cantano particolarmente bene cantano
così bene da convincere i marinai a
buttarsi nel mare per ascoltarle meglio
e poi ad annegare e coulisse era molto
curioso e voleva sentire il canto delle
sirene però Logicamente non voleva
buttarsi a mare morire quindi che cosa
fece fece mettere dei tappi a tutti i
suoi compagni di viaggio e si fece
legare all'albero maestro della nave
così potesse sentire le sirene però non
poter buttarsi Ma che cos'è che dicevano
queste sirene ad Ulisse dicevano Oh
Glorioso Ulisse vanto di tutte le tue
genti noi sappiamo cosa è successo a
noi ti conosciamo vieni da noi
ascoltaci tu che sei grande
lo glorificavano no E a me sembra un po'
la stessa situazione in cui si è trovato
Claudio con un sacco di persone che lo
glorificavano Ah tu diventerai qualcuno
ascoltaci
l'episodio di Ulisse è sempre stato
Visto come espressione del suo ingegno
perché appunto si inventa questo
stratagemma per non cascare nel mare
ascoltando le sirene Però io voglio
vederti qualcosa di diverso io voglio
credere che quelle corde siano un
simbolo che Ulisse non fosse veramente
legato da qualcosa dalle corde ma fosse
legato a qualcosa a casa a quello che
voleva nel profondo Però com'è che
facevo Ulisse a sapere che cosa
desiderava nel profondo e com'è che
facciamo noi a scoprirlo come possiamo
fare allora lui Odissea l'abbiamo detto
no è il poema del ritorno e ritorno in
greco si dice nostos da cui deriva la
nostra parola nostalgia proprio da
nostos ritorno e algos doloroso la
nostalgia è il dolore del ritorno e
Ulisse per tutta l'Odissea non fa
nient'altro che seguire la nostalgia
Se non l'avesse fatto sarebbe rimasto da
Calypso che era una bellissima dea che
gli prometteva di tutto è avrebbe
trovato la felicità lì oppure se sarebbe
sposato Nausica che era molto più
giovane e bella della sua Sposa Penelope
invece no Ulisse poteva fare qualsiasi
cosa una scelta una seguire la sua
nostalgia ed è quello che dobbiamo fare
anche noi dobbiamo seguire il dolore del
ritorno e non significa voler tornare al
passato o vivere nel passato tornare
indietro nel tempo no no significa
semplicemente andare a rivedere le cose
che ci hanno Resi felici in passato e
portarle nel nostro presente questo è
seguire la nostalgia
o nostalgia del mio ex fidanzato perché
perché era un amore sincero benissimo
nel profondo tu desideri un amore
sincero o nostalgia dei miei vent'anni
perché perché ero spensierato Ecco che
in questo momento tu desideri
spensieratezza quando Claudio si è
chiesto di che cosa avesse nostalgia a
risposte che avevamo nostalgia della sua
famiglia di quando era piccolo e passava
tantissimo tempo in famiglia capito
l'avvocato il manager quello che Claudio
voleva nel profondo era una famiglia
tutta sua e qui quando rispondiamo alla
domanda che cos'è Che cos'è che desidero
nel profondo dove voglio tornare ce ne
viene subito un'altra che ci tiene
svegli la notte e se non riesco a
ritrovare un amore sincero e se non
riesco a ritrovare la spensieratezza In
altre parole e se non riesco a tornare a
Itaca
Ulisse ci mise 10 anni a tornare 10 e
noi troppo spesso ci fermiamo ancora
prima di partire ci fermiamo dopo pochi
mesi o dopo qualche anno il punto non è
che non ce la possiamo fare il punto è
che è troppo spesso ci fermiamo troppo
presto però Ulisse alla fine l'abbiamo
detto no è tornato prima però purtroppo
è stato sbalzato a causa di un naufragio
sull'isola dei Feaci dove ha incontrato
il re alcino e gli ha raccontato la sua
storia non ha lasciato che fossero le
sirene a raccontare la sua storia
glorificarlo l'ha raccontata lui come
piangendo
un bel pianto liberatorio il pianto che
si fa quando ti rendi conto che hai
perso qualcosa e proprio nel momento in
cui ti rendi conto che hai perso la cosa
più importante ritrovi qualcos'altro
ritrovi qualcosa che nel quadro di prima
non c'era e in questo invece sì ritrovi
la prospettiva e finalmente la vita
acquista profondità e allora io vi ho
detto tutto quello che sentivo di
dovervi dire oggi vi chiedo solo se
posso Un'ultima cosa Stasera quando
sarete tranquilli nella vostra cucina
nella vostra camera da letto da soli
lasciatevi trasportare dalla nostalgia
Sì all'inizio sarà difficile magari vi
verrà da piangere È normale però non
fatevi fermare lasciatevi trasportare
dalla nostalgia perché è vero che
all'inizio Vi porterà ad essere un po'
tristi Vi porterà a piangere però alla
fine vi porterà a casa
[Applauso]